this is the attwater's prairie chicken a  century ago there were a million of them  roaming around today less than 100 are  left in the wild and are considered one  of the most endangered birds in North  America they are native to the coastal  areas of Texas and Louisiana attwater's  prairie chickens are small averaging  about a foot and a half in size and  weighing two pounds they prefer short  and tall grass in their habitats and  have a diverse diet including grass  roots flowers seeds and insects  urbanization and other forms of habitat  loss have been one of the major factors  in the steep decline of their population  the Houston Zoo runs one of the captive  breeding programs to help reintroduce  these critically endangered birds to the  wild this is the attwater's prairie  chicken  you